everyone Siwan drove with Collider and I
am here with everyone behind corporate
animals first of all thank you all so
much for coming in I sincerely
appreciate it thank you right as I was
saying a second ago I want to give a
huge thank you to Kia Telluride for
being an amazing sponsor for an indie
site like us we need to have sponsors
and key has been amazing you think I'm
joking with you I can probably make it
happen for you okay please do looking
right at her I like black tinted windows
let me tell you something I'm just being
Frank about it that I think they're the
people that run here probably know her
work and would say we want to give her a
car okay by the way this was caught off
on a real effin tangent and I just want
to say that just real quick many many
years ago this guy and I did an
interview here on Main Street for Cedar
Rapids and yet great film and before the
site before Collider was it was still
like yeah I'm still up and coming and
and I'm just say thank you again for
that interview and you know I appreciate
I have very fond memories of that of all
the press on that movie and your
interview in particular as well so thank
you for helping get the word out about
Brown star insurance and see her happy
so uh first of all I am so excited to
see your film and it premieres I believe
tomorrow night 30 so I hate asking the
generic thing but no one will have seen
the film yet or barely anyone will have
seen the film who's watching this
interview so can you talk a little bit
about what it's about
sure so corporate animals is about this
is the story of a small company and with
a terrible tyrannical boss played by
Demi Moore and they go on a
team-building retreat
and they hire a great outdoorsman played
by myself handsome a guy you associate
with extreme sports and extreme living
and then they go on this team-building
retreat they go spelunking which is a
crazy word for caving and they're in a
cave and there's a cave-in and they're
trapped for a long time and terrible
terrible terrible things happen that are
also hilarious I think I did a good job
someone take this for me descriptions
character was extra negative just like
she's horrible I do love the feedback
and now that we are giving now that we
are giving feedback you did lean into
the in you know the description of the
spelunking instructor like keep this
work on it for the next interview after
me oh wait there is no here of marinus
is it for you guys talk a little bit
about how you got involved in the
project and what was it about the script
that said I want I have to do this movie
I want to do this movie I read the
script and really loved it I am a fan of
the writer of the script is named Sam
Bain he's incredible he created the show
peep show wrote for Lions he is really
really talented and the script is just
funny period and then when they started
to put the cast together it really just
sort of sealed the deal for me it's an
ensemble piece and I think everyone is
coming at this film in like a different
way everybody's bringing a different
kind of heat and then on top of that we
got Patrick Brice and I'm also a fan of
his so it's sort of a no-brainer
like I've realized that I'd skip to the
casts I forgot about you know I know
it's there so I went back what you'd
also like one thing that's really cool
about this movie too is like every
single person is a great comedian but
also a great dramatic actor as well
saying that as the tone of this movie
was such that you know we want it to be
really funny but we also wanted to play
as real as possible and these are all
people that know how to do that really
well haven't spoken about what was it
about the script well for me I get to
play like a lot of supporting characters
a lot of time
this was like a role where I was kind of
in almost every scene and and for a lot
of the cast I think because we're more
character actors a lot of us like I
think it was really cool for us to be in
every scene of a movie and really have
like a crazy arc from like the beginning
to end because the characters go through
some really extreme circumstances and
Patrick always wanted the humor to be
really grounded so it was almost like we
were tapping into like dramatic things
that diamonds and while still making a
comedy so that was really exciting you
know that what's great is in this movie
everybody has their moment nobody's left
out it's not like sometimes you see
films where there's a smaller role and
it's not flushed out it doesn't have you
know a real beginning middle and end and
everybody in this has a real complete
story it's very rich great writing I
mean there's just no way that this
wasn't gonna like take just all the
right wrong turns you know in the best
way and I mean obviously for me I
haven't had a chance to play anything
like this before and it just was too
good to not say yes I feel like I've
talked too much already
ya know actually so my company produced
this movie and so we had we sort of had
we're on top of this idea from the very
beginning and it never stopped feeling
super exciting and fresh and completely
ridiculous in the most fun way so and
and Patrick came in very early in the
development process as well with sam
bein the writer and my producing partner
mike Falbo and and it just was like an
avalanche yeah yes snowball I said
Avalanche admit snowball and it's smart
funny Emily is a bunch of snow avalanche
is cooler than a snow ball alright so
you can see it's smart funny and it has
some real meaningful moments I'm very
curious for all of you guys before
filming again is you're looking at the
script you're looking at the schedule
what's the scene that you are absolutely
dreading and what's the scene that you
are most excited to film
I know dreading my character have to eat
newts live mutes because we're really
hungry and me find them floating in a
dirty dirty pond of water and I was
dreading that
because I don't know what they were
gonna be made of but I didn't know what
was gonna happen but it was gross that
was really gross yeah yeah my character
I definitely have to like and also we
had like an amazing like makeup and
special effects team shout out to galaxy
or awesome or the entire team but the
the arm that I had to eat was pretty
gnarly stuff like it looked amazing
there was like hair follicles coming out
of the outside but you did that though I
ripped into it I only had to do it like
once or twice cuz I was like I bit into
it I was like this it just looked real
and it was heavy so it felt like a real
harm what did it taste like Oh
galaxy said--they cuz she like put the
concoction in there like she made the
like blood tendon concoction she said
all right so we got some like you know
chocolate syrup in there we got some
coconut jerky and she said it's vegan um
but she said think of it as um a sweet
smoky luau and I was like cool Coco Coco
cool
so I unpacked that and I ate the arm so
pretty crazy which scene though for you
were you either super excited to do or
scared shitless I'm well the the the my
I'm sort of in the very beginning in the
movie like this adventure guy so I was
sort of excited about the the
team-building exercises those are always
sort of big fun physical set PC things
and then I'm also a little
claustrophobic so there's a there's some
caving shots that that just that I was
dreading more than I actually had a
problem with on the day like just the
dread was there but then not when I was
doing
I was just at yes you know I'm a
professional and I just I reach deep
down and I nailed it
thank you I didn't have any that I
dreaded I I think I was hit with the
reality of like eight page scenes and
that was like something when you're
reading it I didn't it didn't really
like normally it's like a you know two
three pages and when we stepped in our
very first day it was like an eighth
page scene where I'm speaking almost the
entire time in monologues and so that
kind of like the scenes that I I love so
many of them I don't know I think the
ones right I think are I hate to even
say this word but there's something
where he's saying I did something to him
which I would never do to anybody and
well let it be like it but that was
actually a lot of fun and my like being
able to take a stand on my position on
feminism it was excellent
I'm always curated oh sorry no no that's
it I'm always curious about the editing
process because that's the final rewrite
so what did you learn in the editing
room while cutting and what was like in
the editing room while cutting and also
maybe what did you learn from early
friends and family screenings impacted
the finished film yeah well I mean with
all of my movies I've gone through the
process of you know screening early cuts
to friends and family and other
filmmakers and I found it to just be the
most invaluable stage of the process
it's also the most gut-wrenching and you
really have to surrender your ego and
you're literally saying you know watch
the worst iteration of my movie and tell
me what's wrong with it
but if you can do that it's important
because I think going through that
process is what makes your movie good
and it sort of trims the fat and you're
able to see what you know you make you
know clarify your themes and what you
want the movie to be and so it was
really encouraging with this movie
because I worked with my editor Chris
Tomlin who's edited every single project
that I've done so he's someone I'm super
comfortable with and have a great
rapport with
and I think you know we were a luckily
the first like the first screenings felt
really tight the first like screenings
felt like we had something you know we
could see it there in those early first
you know painful to watch cuts and so
you know going from there to whittling
it down to what it is now was just it
was it was really exciting because it's
just it at least in my mind kept getting
better you know everyone who's been
coming in we've been playing get to know
your Sundance attendee it's a few fun
questions I promise these are homeless
and so for the cast
what TV show would you love to guest
star on and what TV show would you love
to guest direct I would love just
because I'm such a Sam Bane fan to bring
back peep show and guest direct an
episode of Peep Show
I've told Sam if I ever go to the UK he
needs to get everyone together to meet
me it's like a make-a-wish Foundation
and type things I'm so obsessed but I'm
tired sorry my brain is like starting to
like I did think though in a delayed
response what was maybe one of the more
difficult things for me and that was
being drug through Jimmy gets drug
through the dirt she also has to rappel
down a cave wall like you're doing all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] and then you're like
eight pages that's that's not that's not
going to work it was it was I loved
search party so I love it search party I
would love to do that I'd be awesome do
that is have to be a current show I
would love to guests are on happy days
okay that just feels like can we make
that happen
so up my alley as far as directing goes
I'd love to direct the Kaminski method
fun show it's a good it's a great show
do you remember this is my next question
what's film scared you as a kid
sleepaway camp I couldn't sleep for a
lie
two months after that movie I saw it
when I was like nah eight or nine that
is too early hey Julie scared me as a
kid Monster Squad
I watched Monster Squad and I needed to
call my grandmother afterwards to
reassure me that it like wasn't real I
watched it when I was like I was six
years old or seven years old and it
really [ __ ] me up is it weird that
nothing I watched as a kid no I watch
Forensic Files to go to sleep i watch
Ted Bundy show the other night to go to
sleep Wow here's my last question for
you guys do you remember when you were
growing up was there like a performance
or a movie that you saw and said and
that's how you got wanted to be in the
entertainment industry I'm always
curious if like what that if you
remember what that switch was that said
oh my god I want to do that yeah I when
I was a kid I used to watch the show
called all that and it was like this you
know a lot of Nickelodeon stars so I
wanted to do that I wanted to be an
actor like from that I just wanted to
like do comedy and sketches and stuff
like that and then as I got a little
older then I would watch SNL with my
grandma like all the time whenever she
babysat me I was like oh that's the
version of that okay I see but my intro
to that was all that for me it was a no
brainer it was a Eddie Murphy on
Saturday Night Live like he just
captured my imagination so completely
and he made me want to do comedy
thank you I just kind of didn't think
cuz I grew up in India so I never
thought I would be in Hollywood first of
all cuz Bollywood is very different it's
like very there's like a lot of nepotism
everyone's like someone's like son or
daughter or something if they're in
movies
and so I just kind of came here and I
did theater in college and then gotta
agent and then I was like I guess I'm
doing this now so it really didn't but
my favorite movie growing up cambios is
mrs. Doubtfire that's what I just
watched so I have a couple of weird when
so there was between funny girl and on a
clear day which a lot of people haven't
seen which is also Barbra Streisand and
Katharine Hepburn and Philadelphia Story
and then the real deciding factor is my
neighbor who I used to read scripts to
because she spoke English but didn't
read was an actress named Nastassja
Kinski and we lived in the same
apartment building and she had I would
read scripts aloud to her and I thought
whatever she's got I want that well she
did Tess
like [ __ ] but Roman Polanski brought her
she's a German so we would literally
just sit and I would read it aloud
because she could speak English but
couldn't read it as well so that she
would know what it was and I was 15 and
she was like 17 to meet Nastassja Kinski
for me I mean it's kind of a wide swath
like her very early on it was sucker
Brothers movies like Naked Gun and a top
secret and then I mean really the jerk
was one of the first movies that I
watched and was like I don't understand
how this something could be so funny you
know and just being so completely taken
and blown away but then when it came to
like me actually thinking about making
movies is something I'd want to do it
was Twin Peaks fire walk with me which I
know is the weirdest [ __ ] thing to
say but it's like that was a movie that
really spoke to me and so you know going
forward all my stuff has kind of been an
intersection of that type of that type
of vibe sorry I said buy it by the way
so vibey the reason I'm once again I
want to give first of all again thank
you
for coming in thank you I want to give a
huge thank you again to Kia Telluride
for being a great sponsor I mean it
sincerely I hope your film does
incredibly well
Sundance cannot wait to see it thank you
Steve
thank you
you